all right why don't we give away some
memberships pal we're going to be giving
away some free memberships and it's
going to be connected to something that
I think is really important
patriotism and nationalism for a long
time particularly in corporate media the
right has sort of monopolized patriotism
and nationalism or the sort of blend of
the two that's now standard Republican
apologetics I've always argued that this
is what I call toxic patriotism support
the troops means support any harebrained
military engagement that our president
sends our troops into and put a yellow
ribbon on your car right that's toxic
patriotism to me real patriotism real
support the troops means we take
military action seriously as a last
resort in order to honor the fact that
we don't need a draft because we have a
volunteer military and we take care of
our vets when they come home that's
supporting the troops to me or the toxic
patriotism is feeling that you're better
than others because you happen to be
born between a set of imaginary lines
merely by chance through no work of your
own that you did or for example having
pride and the great weapons we have with
which we can kill other people so I've
been advocating for a long time for a
better patriotism a progressive
patriotism and that has to do with pride
in real accomplishments right we take
care of the least among us in a serious
way we value urban areas and have really
elegantly designed cities that work well
that's an accomplishment to take pride
in as Alain de Botton has written about
many times really great scientists and
teachers are the most revered people in
our country rather than people famous
merely for being famous those are the
types of things I believe are a more
progressive patriotism that we should be
proud of so how does this relate to free
memberships Pat that's what Pat is
wondering right yes I think so most are
you Jennifer karein a viewer and
supporter of the show is sponsoring for
free memberships and because we just got
past the Independence Day holiday here
in the US fourth of July holiday the
requirement for the
free membership is you're going to put
together by one paragraph letter to us
right
it could be prose it could be a short
personal story it could be a poem
doesn't matter the format but it has to
be about expressing progressive
patriotism okay it might be about a way
in which you volunteered that you
believe is progressive patriotism it
might be a haiku about a better
nationalism that is really something
progressives can be proud of instead of
we've got great guns to kill other
people with and we kick people out from
our country when they come in right
progressive patriotism it's about a
paragraph whatever format you like you
write it in at david pakman.com you go
to contact and then you fill that out
you put the title for your email
progressive patriotism the best four of
these progressive patriotism letters
will get free memberships for one year
year thank you to longtime supporter
Jennifer crane I like this a lot because
just a couple weeks ago we had the ger
inspired unintelligible rant contest yes
and there were so many eccentric
incoherent poems that came in after that
short I think this is a 180-degree turn
after that membership contest we want to
grow our membership base and we'll do it
any number of ways and Jennifer karein
we thought what we're doing this around
the fourth of July what we look could we
do what better thing than messages of
progressive patriotism okay so about a
paragraph whatever you want to write
david pakman.com contact the subject is
progressive patriotism will give this
maybe four or five days or something
like that and then early next week we
will select the four winners